we all were paying attention yesterday
to the contracts that were paid out to a
couple of tight ends it started with
george kittle
look he wanted a lot more than he got
but the reality was given the position
he plays and the franchise tag money and
everything else that's going on and the
way he plays the injury risk
he had to take what was on the table 40
million guaranteed
for injury 30 million of that fully
guaranteed at signing
15 million dollars per year in new money
it really does
take the tight end market to a new level
george kittle deserving of every penny
and
the 49ers with a keeper and another guy
that they stumbled into
and great job by john lynch and kyle
shanahan a mid-round pick
who's become the best tight end in
football
yeah no question about it and they got
that done and they've gotten some deals
done
uh john lynch has done a great job in
san francisco with what he's done
getting these guys tied up and they have
a core and look like they're gonna be a
good team for
a long time and that window is wide open
over the next few years with jimmy
garoppolo
if he can do what they think he's going
to do we haven't quite seen it yet when
it matters most we didn't see it in the
fourth quarter of the super bowl but
they think he's going to get another
chance to go back there and get it done
in the fourth quarter the next time
whether that's just
this year or next year or the year after
they have set themselves up
very well for the future and and happy
to see that tight end position
finally get some love you know we don't
give it in the pro football hall of fame
it doesn't get that much love and in
contracts it doesn't get that much love
but it's nice to see him
uh get what he deserves because i do
think he is the best tight end of
football travis kelsey is pretty close
and he got him some money yesterday too
yeah and you know one last thing on kit
we talked about this yesterday and i
think it's critical this year with no
fans at these games
you need someone who's going to light
the fire under the team and kittle's got
that mentality he's going to get the
team fired up he's going to get him
riled up and ready to go even if no one
is there for any of the 49ers home games
and that's going to be a huge huge
weapon that kyle shanahan is going to
need to unleash for every home game you
mentioned travis kelsey
you know i'm starting to think you look
at how long kelsey's been around and
he's on the wrong side of 30 or close to
it
and you know with all these weapons they
have and with patrick mahomes there
at some point do they try to develop the
next travis kelsey well
kelsey gets his contract not nearly as
lucrative as kittles but
but he's on his third contract it's a
great third contract
for travis kelsey and this gets back to
what we were talking about earlier
when you have a quarterback that is
willing to do a ridiculously
team-friendly deal and
tie himself to the team for 12 total
years
you got a lot of flexibility to sign the
guys that you want to keep
and to work it out so you continue to
have tyree kill
sammy watkins travis kelsey and now
you've got clyde edwards hilaire the
rookie running back
on a five-year deal and mahomes for 12.
they are they are laying the foundation
you know and again it was by no means
easy last year shireen they were down
double digits in every playoff game
but still they're laying the foundation
of a team that is at or near the top of
the stack
every single year for the rest of the
decade and no question about it you love
what the chiefs have done again tying up
that core
chiefs and the 49ers both and and they
are set for
for the future and that window is wide
open and mahomes is going to be there
for a really long time however long that
is whether it's the next 10 years or not
but but for the foreseeable future
anyway he is their quarterback
and we've seen since he came to the
league and became the starter in his
second season he's been the best
quarterback
in the nfl undoubtedly i don't think you
can argue that point
with what he's done with the super bowl
mvp and a league mvp so this is a team
that's built to win and it's built to
win for
the next few years and maybe it's the
next dynasty in the nfl replacing
the patriots and maybe not they're
awfully hard to come by and i would have
thought aaron rodgers had more than one
super bowl title
in his career to this point he doesn't
have they're really hard to win and as
you said it wasn't easy for the chiefs
last year but this does look like a team
that's set up to at least
contend for the next few years
and you know you got some guys on that
team that are making some big boasts
about total numbers
chris jones tyree kill six or more
said jones seven said tyree kill that
that's just ridiculous and my guess is
andy reid has shut
that stuff down you cannot be thinking
that way you just have to go out and do
it we never heard the patriots talk that
way
you can't set the bar that high there
are too many things that you can't
control
that can derail your season especially
this
season with the uncertainties arising
from covert 19.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports